نضب الينا من سقل في ايطاليا فرانشيسكا
البانيز مقرره الامم المتحده الخاصه
المعنيه بحاله حقوق الانسان في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله مرحبا بك سيده
فرانشيسكا وضع كارثي بتوصيف منظمات الامم
المتحده المعنيه بمتابعه الصحه والوضع
الغذائي والوضع الانساني بتوصيف المنظمات
الانسانيه المعنيه
بكل الحاله الانسانيه التي يعيشها الانسان
في
غزه
حقوقيا اين
وصلت هذه الصوره الكارثيه من وجهه نظرك
على الصعيد
الدولي اذا مرحبا بك سلمى من وجهه نظر
عالميه هذا الوضع
كارثي كما هو الوضع الانساني ليس هنالك اي
بند من القانون الدولي الانساني لم يتم
خرقه في هذه العمليه التي تجري في غزه
هنالك جرائم حرب بالتاكيد
لانه ليس هنالك اي احترام واي اعتبار في
هذا
القصف الشامل هم ونوع القنابل التي
يستخدمونها من الواضح انه ليس هنالك كمبدا
للتمييز بين الاهداف العسكريه
والمدنيه في حاله القصف بين المدنيين
والمقاتلين ليس هنالك احترام وليس هنالك
لل التناسبيه او اتخاذ اي احتياطات
بالتالي من الواضح ان هنالك جرائم ترتكب
بشكل متكرر لكن في رايي هنالك بعض الجرائم
التي تصل الى حد الجرائم ضد الانساني لان
قصف مثلا مخيم اللاجئين او المناطق
الماهوله بالسكان او ذات الكثافه السكانيه
من الواضح والمعروف انها ستؤدي الى قتل
اعداد عاليه من المدنين مثل مخيم جباليه
هذا الامر قد يصل
الى الاباده وايضا التجويع التجويع
المتعمد الذي
تسبب وكان واضحا منذ البدايه هذا امر في
حقيقه الامر يتعدى جرائم الحرب وكل شيء كل
سلسله الجرائم التي ترتكبها اسرائيل ايضا
بمنطق وعلى والتي تهدف
الى طرد طرد الفلسطينين واجبارهم على ترك
اراضيهم ايضا تكون هي جرائم ضد الانسانيه
لان اللغه التي مستخدمه لغه الاباده على
الرغم من ان وسائل الاعلام والساسه
الغربيين ينكرون هذا الامر لكن ننظر الى
الارقام هنالك 20 الف شخص قد قتلوا وهناك
سيده فرانشيسكا وهناك سيده فرانشيسكا ايضا
معطيات مهمه جدا كما تذكرين بان يعني
السياق الذي جرت فيه الانتهاكات الكبيره
لحاله حقوق الانسان في يعني هذا العصر
الحديث كانت يعني البشريه لم تصل ربما
مثلا في فتره الحرب العالميه الثانيه الى
ثا قها الخاص بحقوق الانسان ولم تكتبه
كتبته فيما بعد وايضا لم تكن مثلا
المجموعات البشريه تدري بان هناك انتهاكات
بهذا الحجم الان كل شيء مكتوب وكل شيء
مرصود وكل شيء موثق وتجري امام اعين
الجميع وهنا يتدخل عامل السياسه الى اي
درجه تشعري بانكم انتم مكبلون كمقرر الامم
متحده لحقوق الانسان في فلسطين بالتدخل
السياسي بالسطو السياسي
هنالك عده امور بدايه بعد كل شيء نحن بشر
وانا ربما اقوم هذا الامر وربما هو في هذه
المناسبه مناسبه الميلاد المجيد التي هي
المناسبه الاحزن انا اشعر
بشعور ياس لم اشعر به من قبل لانه في
حقيقه الامر انا ارى ان الفلسطينيين الذين
يخبروننا بقصصهم والجرائم التي يعيشونها
يتم نقلها عبل التلفاز ولا يحصل اي شيء
ولا يبدو ان هنالك اي شيء يوقف اله
الاختيال التي التي التي التي سماها بعض
الصحفيين الاسرائيليين هذا الاسم بالتالي
هنالك الكثير من الشعور بالاحباط لكن ايضا
كمحامي انا
اخشى مما سيحدث للنظام كما ذكرتي وانت
محقه بهذا الامر النظام القانوني الذي
نمتلكه اليوم قد كان قد صمم من اجل منع
القسوه
والوحشيه و قمع و الناس والذي ما رايناه
في ا عقاب الحرب العالميه الثانيه وخاصه
خلال
فتره المحرق لانها كانت في حقيقه الامر
كانت هذه الاباده وكان هذه هذه التمييز ضد
اليهود الذي استمر لسنوات طويله ونرى هنا
نمطا من التمييز والتفرقه ضد
الفلسطينيين يحصل وكشخص غربي اقول اننا
تعلمنا لم نتم
ما ترض له اليهود في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه شكرا جزيلا لك من سقل في ايطاليا
فرانشيسكا البانيز مقرره الامم المتحده
الخاصه المعنيه بحاله حقوق الانسان في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله شكرا جزيلا لك
على المشاركه معنا